hi Sean you're on the air they're giving
me a radio show and nightly talk show I
would love for you to share with me any
sort of wisdom this is the first time
I'm going on the air you know I should
offer him JD first show cuz JD's gold
cuz imagine when you get on with this
guy JD I understand you what worked for
the Howard Stern Show
how'd you get that job or some way my
ratings are going through the roof
people can't believe what they're
hearing if you don't mind me asking I
don't know you that well but is it true
you spend $10,000 on webcam girls what
do you think is that a is that a home
run or what can't wait to talk to you
tonight man yeah I run on there three
years or didn't wash my sheets or yeah
well you got it all you got to do say
how is it for three years you didn't
wash your sheets tell him the story here
Sean when he's a guest on your show
ask him didn't my strew through your
pants in the closet burn through your
pants JD do you want to do a comedy show
here's your guy yeah on the floor and
then cockroaches stole my couch oh
here's a good one Sean just say to him
so Jake real JD why did you reveal your
engagement on Twitter instead of on
Howard Stern Show you work for the
Howard Stern Show and you gave that
exclusive to Twitter go ahead you know
why don't you wait for tomorrow's that
great that's radio gold my friend Power
Hour whatever
that's know I'm asking you now so that
you can interest 10 hours from that well
you know what Sean interview him about
when JD said Seinfeld was Letterman's
best guest and not me tweeted that you
know who was Lauren's best guess
yeah sure go ahead wanna see a really
great guest
yeah I don't want it I don't want to say
anything so go ahead JD you said time
foul but whatever you do don't ask JD
about his finances because here's the
answer you'll get you hear this JD
$6,000 oh now that's radius if you get
JD on this is radius bold that's right
you got to ask him when you're on the
air with him how he almost drowned from
a water slide at a theme park in two
feet of water are you willing going this
guy show her know